sono tutti ragazzi benvenuti avessero
video sono fa vj e da ci sono sul nuovo
videogame per la libera che l'ho
cambiato perché quello di prima che
avevo era una roba che tra l'altro che
tra l'altro ho cambiato perché quello di
prima è quello che avevo prima per
girarlo mi serviva il carro attrezzi e
quindi adesso è più pratico prima di
passare al sir il gioco di oggi e best
friends best fit che io credevo si
chiamasse best friends
ma i notai firenze che un gioco che
potete scaricare gratuitamente sull'app
store utilizzando anche link che lascio
qui sotto nella descrizione che ho
scaricato stamattina ecco che bella
l'icona è stupenda per aprirlo come al
solito bisogna dire a siri cosa fare
tanto hanno aggiornato oppure l'ipad
quindi ciao siri ha imparato un nuovo
trucco per saperne di più basta dire e
in siria e in siria ha imparato a
parlare puglies c preparato legno che ci
metterebbe in siria apri best fiends
parla non è peccato lo sa come si dice
che figlio l'arci posso che è brava a
fare passi da gigante brava la apple
brava mi sorprende ogni volta che la per
ad appena famosa temi è sbagliato io
come si gira lo schermo nel regno di
minuti a regnava la sipra famiglia
girarlo schermo fa avvicinare lo scherzo
è bello come fa sapere che sono famiglia
addio l'ora che a questo era un account
che avevo creato sull'apple store tipo
sei anni fa ma anche di più secondo me è
ecco perché si girava perché non si può
girare lo vedi proprio sì ok ok allora
ai lati del video ci saranno le barre
nere che coprirò con dei pony divertenti
per riempire lo spazio ai ragazzi siamo
su best friends che ancora non so come
si non ho idea di come se giochi quindi
ancora non ciao sono io temper uno dei
fake
aiutami a raccogliere i blocchi con la
foglia verde va bene ora ho capito ho
capite ma io non sono bravo a questi
giorni qui da tre il più sky uno dei più
scaricati sull'app store stop
sono bravissimo sono un fenomeno visto
c'è una difficoltà che manco i bambini
nel regno di minuti a regnava la pace
regnava poi sono arrivato io ha deciso
di far casino grande grande cosa cosa
grande grande vai che regna la pace
regnava ecco infatti arrivato al
meteorite per gli è esplosa la suocera
permetto lite si è schiantato contro il
monte boom
non so perché si chiami così questo
monte presta attenzione i traguardi del
livello oppure paga il prezzo mi sta
minacciando cosa ci ha messo la strizza
paurosa aver presta attenzione dai cosa
devo fare che con questo tizio è un figo
a ok mi venivano in mente questi
incredibili mosse però dicono questa c'è
vorrei dire ho visto un sacco di gente
che ci giocava ma non ne sono ancora
cavallo skill armi che bello nella
montagna fuoriesce qualcosa di terribile
lo sai cosa orribile mia madre quando
prendi 4 scuola quella orribile accedi a
facebook non faremo spar né sulla tua
bacheca e beh no io non sono così io ci
ho meno barban meteora colpi il monte
boom trasformando gli slarghi in un'orda
di voraci creature contrattacca e un
contratto che è contratta chiamo draghi
sono arrivati a questa è uno slide
ragazzi non oso pensare gli occhiali
quanto costino per gli slide blocchi
rossi hanno fatto un po di danni ma
saline rai con i verdi il verde il mio
colore
però ho scoperto di non essere daltonico
allinea mi verdi ragazzi cosa vi devo
dire
è una cosa un po strana perché non sono
solito a giocare a queste cose quindi
probabilmente sto facendo delle mosse da
pivello
ma chi se ne frega c'è sempre la prima
volta buona ragazzi durante questa ma do
cose ben fatte grazie grazie mille bravo
collega giocavo ho capito ho capito
calmo calmate bimbo mix 95
ecco accesso alla schermata come samuel
samuel sa che cos'è samuel aparo
richiamo sarà esteso non lorenzo vabbè
basta che migliaia di manti chiamami
anche giovanna se vuoi questa sono io a
questa è la mia samuel a quella che
conosco io
tiepolo zoe l'importante che siano
aziende contenti poi chissenefrega
ma la pista roba non posso più tornare
indietro fermi per allora faccio così ma
dopo se chao pin domen alema cosa questa
apocalisse devo prendere forza le verdi
verona primo le verdi ciao ciao bello
stato bello che uno share di una chiave
cosa mi serve grande grande magari mi ha
fatto schifo la partita però intanto io
clicco grande a caso è il contratto qui
chi a quincy qui non so manco leggere o
un ragno essere un brutto anatroccolo
grande non è per quello che che non
sembra proprio un ragno inserì belluno
potenzia l'attacco ma in base a chi se
no vabbè bellissimo sì lo so avevo
intuito che fossero i fiori quindi
ammazza latina e botte per una donna ma
neanche per otto fiorito era così
devastante tanto sta cosa che se va bene
ciao ciao bello di endo menale e ramazza
cioè questo è proprio il massimo della
vita è una e la distruzione totale
dell'essere umano proprio fantastico
tutto
ho vinto gli slarghi hanno portato i
nostri amici sul monte boom andiamo a
salvarli
ora che bello al monte bue come se la
ghini a quest'uomo questo vulcano è il
momento di chiedere a siri ragazzi cosa
ne pensa siri cosa ne pensi degli acari
meteora che devi uccidere il profumo di
banana 6 gentile a chiederlo ma davvero
non importa quello che penso io tesoro
ma certo che mi importa quello che dice
ma cosa pensi di me
6 gentile a chiederlo ma davvero non
importa quello che penso io
le donne si canta mina canzone meglio di
no sono una campana stone umana ma cosa
dici ricordami che alle otto e mezza o
un appuntamento dall'estetista per farmi
strappare i per i i peli pubici non hai
nessun promemoria sole otto e trenta è
un appuntamento dall'estetista per far
miss trattare i peli pubici allora segna
mica un appuntamento dall'estetista per
farmi strappare i peli pubici ok farmi
ma perché appelli pubblici è una ragazza
sbagliato a scrivere questa è un rimando
aiuto best friend apri best friend sulla
riga allarga e lecca lecca erika lecca
lecca lecca
erika qualche ora da ragazzi che un
crudo che l'episodio è stato
wow perché ogni volta che ascolto siri e
ogni volta che gioca un mito game per
ipad
rimango di stucco merosi video con pato
che l'episodio ragazzi come sento
seguito è piaciuta lasciato argomento è
un mi piace neanche a faccia di facebook
con il video tratta da tiziana sensi
aversi discrezione ci vediamo in questo
video bella ragazzi si rifà vj su
youtube che cazzo fa ha certamente
studiato a oxford